this is a millionaire theme our we're
talking to people with million-dollar
net worths and asking them how they did
it a millionaire is not someone that
makes a million dollars a year a
millionaire is someone that has a net
worth of a million dollars or more and
that worth is defined as your assets
minus your liabilities what you own
minus what you owe equals at least a
million dollars so you could have a
bunch of paid for real estate you could
have a pile of cash you could have a mix
of that your 401k is in the equation
invested in good mutual funds which is
where we're finding most people have
there's a large portion of their wealth
is done just by saving in their 401k if
you want to be a millionaire we're
seeing that over and over and over again
by the way and none of these people are
90 that we've talked to so far we might
talk to a 90 year old but so far they've
all been in their 50s except one
gentleman who was 64 so 52 to 64 was the
age range that we've talked to today
these are actual millionaires this is
not political hype it is not political
trash where someone's trying to make a
point this is just real people if you
want to know a minute what it takes to
be a millionaire maybe you ought to
listen to real people Gina is with us in
New York City hi Gina how are you hi
Thank You mr. Ensley how are you doing
better than I deserve what is your net
worth 1.6 million sir
awesome very way to go and what is that
invested in what's the breakdown it's
about 750,000 in our home about a half a
million in our business and business
property 360 thousand in retirement and
other the rest and college savings
emergency fund gotcha
how old are you I'm 52 my husband is 48
okay and how much of this one point six
million did you inherit we were actually
blessed to get 100,000 of it from John's
dad when he passed away which we used to
put towards the debt on the business
property insurance how long ago was that
about four years ago okay so basically
you were millionaires before then
yes sir help oh no I'll always take an
extra hundred that's for sure okay your
your range of income during your working
lifetime your household income 42 now
what about 160 awesome very cool
and what is the career field in
corporate world I was actually a
financial advisor for a while on the 401
K field now I run a garage door business
with my husband okay all right he does
all the hard work in the field and I do
everything else
gotcha okay and what are your degrees in
I have a four-year business degree my
husband is a high school graduate who
works incredibly hard has incredibly
honest and that more than makes up for
anything else and it's paid off
obviously very well that's what we hate
and what was your GPA in college
it was about a 3.6 3.6 okay very cool so
how much of this money that you have
your net worth is due to you borrowing
money to invest what we not offense you
didn't borrow money to grow the business
no no we did well except for the that
all the property okay so you did buy the
piece of property with that but that's
paid off now yes and what part does
giving played in your financial plan all
these years not a bigger always we would
like we're looking forward to actually
we are right now Kelly definitely had
any debt right now we are 10 days from
now going to be paying the last seven
thousand dollars off of our home
mortgage all right and then we will be
done so kind of a pre debt-free thing
here cuz I get that free scream today
good so what's the most efficient pair
jeans you all about you know I guess in
my 20s I must have bought a $50 pair of
jeans I don't really remember the last
30 years nineteen dollars okay all right
and how many new cars did you buy before
you had a million dollar net worth one
but it got 150,000 miles on it before I
got rid of it gotcha okay and between
you and your husband how many
non-fiction books do you all read a year
do you think we listen
and a lot of time in vehicles probably
about two one to two a month okay but
audiobooks then huh
yes so he's uh he's on in his first
field called a so he has a lot of time
to be in the car with me what would he
say his favorite book was in the last
year not mine a lot of your stuff um I
did hear a big right now I have to say
when I've been listening to your last
caller and he was just so fantastic I'm
thinking wow my story is so
underwhelming compared to this you know
what no none of these stories none of
these stories are anybody that shot the
moon in one fell swoop everybody all of
us that have made money we've worked our
butts off and saved money it's really
not this this is there's no real big
deal here that's what that's what the
common theme among all of us is and I'm
a multi-millionaire so the same thing
same situation and you know I'd say you
know I didn't sign an NFL contract for
10 million dollars it never happened to
me you know so I could just say I don't
suppose we really brief we had we did
stupid with the big s about 12 years ago
when we still had about 230,000 debt on
our house we purchased the business
where John had worked for several years
actually between the business and the
property we put additional five hundred
and twenty-five thousand dollars of debt
on us we had seven hundred fifty five
thousand dollars worth of debt about 12
years ago and we were too ignorant to be
totally petrified by that well we worked
it off and fortunately it worked out for
us I lived through it as what amounts to
yeah yeah yeah most people have that dip
as well in the in their story so very
cool well you're a great American hero
you and your husband thank you for
owning your own business running it
hard-working folk making this happen a
million six and net worths good to talk
to you Gino god bless hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends thank
you
lost your mind